foreign
[Music]
networks from omics data and my name is
Michel Ivan booking I'm from the
Department of medical bioinformatics
from the University Medical Center in
guttingen in Germany
it's really my great pleasure to present
here at the 10th Annual cancer research
and immuno oncology virtual week and I'd
like to present you
um about graphical models and these
models we use to estimate molecular
networks from high dimensional or mixed
data so
um definitely a topic of huge importance
in the context of cancer
and I'd first like to make you familiar
with the concept how it works and and
why we think that it's and yeah at least
uh yeah a great concept which has a
multiple advantages compared to
um standard correlation based approaches
and I particularly want to show you
um how this framework can be extended to
the multi-ohomics content and
specifically I want to show you
an application where we integrated
transcriptomic data with promoter
missilation in breast cancer
and basically building up on these
models I finally would like to show you
how they can be adapted to also analyze
spatial omic status or many people are
currently talking about spatial
transcriptomics and indeed they are not
yet many approaches available to
basically perform a holistic integration
so including as many information as
possible
into some models and that's basically
a way we propose or many people
currently are pursuing such Direction so
in mathematics that's really a field
where YouTube efforts were done in the
last few years
and
um basically we are very interested in
now using that knowledge to gain
knowledge from multi-onics data or
spatial transcriptomics data for
instance
um let me first make you more familiar
with the concept and for that purpose I
did hear some introductory simulation
where I compare ordinary Pearson's
correlation with partial correlation and
partial correlation said is a graphical
model specifically it corresponds to
abortion graphical model
and what I did here is that I simulated
two genes which are regulated by a
single I called it here regulator which
might be some transcription factor or
whatever
and I simulated the scenario shown here
in the upper left corner so since
regulator determines the expression of
two genes A and B and here on the
um diagonal you have histograms over the
values which I simulated here and
corresponding Scatter Plots are shown in
the upper right corner
and now a correlation based analysis
and yeah quantifies basically the
scatter plot into a number and therefore
I put here question mark in the upper
right corner that you just ask yourself
um how would you now in such a easy
simulation expect this get a plot
between Gene a and Chin d
and let me resolve it so
if we go on one slide said also nicely
scatters on a line but that's pretty
much
um
in contrast to to the simulation we
perform because we basically A and B are
not directly dependent however
considering Just A and B in isolation
such as scatter plot they appear to be
some kind of correlation
and that's simply because of the
individual relationship of Gene a to the
regulator and Gene B to the regulator
also they do not have a relationship in
between
and that's Quantified for instance by
Pearson correlation and I added the
corresponding numbers here so Gene a and
regulator coordinate correlate highly
with um
95 percent and similarly regulator GP
and the number which are indicated here
in red that's the correlation between
Gene A and B and that's still highly
significant with 91 percent
said means
they go on one slide and depict the
corresponding graph that appears to us
as there would be a relationship between
a and b
and that's basically what partial
correlation can address so I simply
calculate here now partial correlations
and we see Gene a regulator still highly
correlated with 0.68 and the same for
regulator Gene B
0.68 both highly significant but the red
number the row now decreases to
something near where MCO so also say lie
on almost on a line basically it's a
partial correlation and diminishes that
means
after correlation can resolve the basic
structure
um of what we simulated also I have to
emphasize that there are no directions
so these partial correlations does not
tell us if a and regulates a regulator
or if the regulator regulates a so
that's something we do not have here but
what is it does is basically that it
considers
um variable simultaneously and allows to
disentangle direct from indirect
relationships and
of course in cancer research that plays
a huge role because in cancer many
things might differ
from normal tissue for instance and
um basically it's a huge importance to
and get rid of a lot of false positive
associations and that's what these kind
of models aim to do
let me Briefly summarize so this
Vanishing partial correlations and these
correspond to conditional independent
statements so I said just conditional
Independence basically phrases what I
just showed you so this is
distinguishing direct from indirect um
relationships and I also want to express
it formally
and at least once or even that's not a
perfectly formally it's more an
intuitive statement it's a corresponding
and formalism and that's basically reads
if a and b are conditionally independent
given C so in our previous example C was
a regulator
then a does not provide any information
for p which is not already contained in
C
and that's basically I'm written here on
the right side as a formula and that
corresponds to Vanishing partial
correlations and basically these
graphical models
um aim to estimate conditional
independent statements
and computational Analysis means that we
need to consider
um
yeah all variables Advanced so we cannot
consider two variables
for instance two gene expression levels
in isolation but we need to consider as
much as possible which can help to
basically reveal if is it now a direct
relationship or indirect relationship
and of course there might be in nowadays
omic status there might be still a lot
of variables hidden and of course
um that still induces many false
positives let's say it like that but as
I tried to show you basically we reduce
at least the number of false positive
associations
and one thing is worth mentioning so and
we are usually dealing with high
dimensional omic status or really many
molecular variables
and as I mentioned we need to estimate
really a lot of power meters
and what I show you here is a plot where
I have on the y-axis the difference
between an estimate of the partial
correlation Matrix and the ground rules
and
um the standard partial correlation
estimates it's already almost
um 100 years
old
and known how to calculate it that's
shown here in red and on the x-axis we
have sample size
and what we basically see is we decrease
sample size and get it gets more and
more difficult to correctly estimate
these partial correlations and therefore
this red line basically increases
and it increases until it reaches a
sample size of n equals 100 which
corresponds to our simulation with M 100
variables so that means if I have even
less measurements or the same order of
magnitude measurements as I have
variables I cannot estimate it or
um if I have slightly more measurements
the hour gets pretty large so I usually
need much more measurements measurements
in samples
um same variables and that's of of
course something which is wildly
feasible so if we are dealing with
for instance really large data sets have
something like 1000 patients and I I'd
like to model let's say 10 000 or even
more rnas or
um different omics layers so
the red one here definitely causes quite
some issues
there are now a lot of research
um happened in last years is
um how can we still infer reasonable
partial correlations and sets
um what we people usually do is a
so-called regularized estimate that's
basically you induce a systematic bias
on your estimate which basically tells
the algorithm I do not expect too many
meaningful associations
so it basically biases all towards
Simplicity and such methods so the blue
line here corresponds to the so-called
covariance shrinkage approach so one
specific kind of
um regularization for graphical models
and at least it
um
the the error does not inflate it
uncontrolled and basically we can also
estimate partial correlations for for
even lower sample sizes and in the lower
left corner I also mentioned a reference
where you can have a look into if you
want to find out more about this and
there's also some code where we can
generate similar plots
well
now of course
um there are a lot of new directions
coming up and
multi-omics is one of the most promising
and directions experimentally in my
opinion and that also
[Music]
generates a lot of computational issues
and basically
we and many other groups try to solve
these issues and I just want to give you
an idea what these issues are so for
instance in multi on mix we might deal
with very different data modalities so
we might have continuous data like gene
expression or gene expression could be
also
incorporated as as count data so if a
really count transcripts or I have
something like categorical data so for
instance mutations
well could be even something important
and One Direction one could go here is
mixed graphical modeling where I
mentioned here also three citations
and what we specifically investigated
um
um is multi-omics for continuous
variables so there might be still a lot
of issues like very omics layer specific
noises or very different amount of edges
between omics layers within omics layers
so edges means associations so if I'm
not mentioning this
and what we suggested is a method we
call it Dragon which stands for
determining regulatory associations
using graphical models on lightly omic
networks where you can also have a look
into a preprint
and given here it under says an archive
number
the method computationally looks like
this
um I will not
um explain too much details about
um how Dragon works but at least I would
like to mention two publication which
were really important for developing
dragons that's here as a chef and
schlimmer paper from 2005 which
introduced
um covariance shrinkage as a method to
estimate partial correlations for high
dimensional omics data
and certain the second one is here by
Bernal where corresponding distributions
were stated so now the distribution said
something we need to estimate two values
and those two methods we combine to a
multi-ohomics setting
and that's what's basically what dragon
isn't in formulas within itsy and that
shown in the upper right corner and
comprehensively shown in the preprint
which I just mentioned before
well when we set up such a new method we
also need to comprehensively and
Benchmark it and the first step we do is
we do some simulation studies
and basically we did four different
studies and I'd like to start here with
a study a and what you see here on these
figures on the y-axis is basically the
performance in recovering the correct
associations in terms of work AUC and on
the x-axis it's corresponding sample
size
and simulation scenario e was
constructed in a very benign scenario
where we basically have two omics layers
and those are
basically equals with respect to the
characteristics
and in that case
we observed here such a blue line and
what's hidden here is a red line which
lies below sets in principles and
covariance shrinkage based estimate of
Africa relations
and as we see both perform identically
so if I have a very controlled setting
and where I do not care about multionics
issues and I just
um this pose as they would belong to the
same
um omics layers dragon and TTM
so that's basically the same but it's
getting more interesting
um if we now introduce systematic
differences between omics layers as I
said there might be huge differences for
instance with respect to
feature size or number of variables and
also Edge densities and that's what we
systematically explored in simulation B
to D and there we see that indeed Dragon
improves quite substantially as
indicated by the blue line which use
usually lies substantially above the red
line
we also benchmarked it against other
available approaches to estimate
um
gaussian graphical models and with
significance levels
and basically all these methods ranked
edges according to false Discovery rate
and that generated these plots the first
rule is what I just showed to you a
comparison to a basically we could call
it one layer Dragon here in red and TGM
and then second to fifth row are the
competing m method and so basically we
see a very similar pattern for each of
the comparisons that Dragon indeed
um so explicitly taking into account
um
multi-ohomics aspect indeed is able to
to improve Amazon Network inference and
substantially
well um
I'd like to present you now
um an example analysis
and they will be considered breast
cancer specimens from tcga and first I'd
like to give you just some sanity checks
which also emphasize
um how a partial correlation analysis
can indeed improve compared to a Pearson
correlation correlation based analysis
and what we did here is we downloaded
these breast cancer specimens from tcta
and restricted the data set to gene
expression levels of transcription
factors and corresponding and promoter
methylation and levels
that made roughly about 3 000 variables
which we included into the model
and now performing an
um correlation based analysis we obtain
a huge amount of significant association
between methylation levels and gene
expression levels in total we obtained
more than 800 000 significant
associations with a false Discovery rate
below o5 basically indicating there are
a lot of dependencies
and associations but as I said those
might be a lot of indirect ones also
and also importantly just a minor
proportion where edges between the
expression of a gene and its
corresponding own promoter methylation
and that's what we basically supposed to
be the dominant effect so what's
basically happening is and you usually
have a methylation of the promoter and
that represses gene expression and
that's also why most of these edges were
negative but as I said I was a low
proportion of that basically what we and
what considers as a most natural way
home isolation effects gene expression
okay let's see what the dragon is doing
first we observe the dragon
substantially reduces the number of
significant methylation gene expression
edges and in fact we are just 769 left
with an FDR below 0.05 and
um
what we observe here is that a high
proportion 43 in number 333 where
associations between the expression of a
gene and the methylation of its promoter
and in also the
um a high proportion of 92 percent so
the predominant proportion where
negative partial combination so that
really
um looks like we have revealed this
process of Ember passing chain
expression via a promoter missilation
so fast it's a sanity check let's call
it like set so that's I'm not saying
particularly exciting it just shows you
a drawback of
um
of correlation based analysis but we are
of course more interested in learning
something about cancer and indeed I
don't want to hide some nice discoveries
so we screened
um
gene expression variables according to
the number of edges to methylation sites
so basically we screen for gene
expression methylation hubs so genes
which
um
basically associate with mm with as many
methylation size as possible and that's
yielded a thing finger party in as top
hit it's cfp 57
and
into first and we observe that the
strongest Edge in this neighborhood of
cfp 57 is is basically its own
methylation site and it has a really low
FDR below 10 to the power minus 100 so
really are clear Association and it's
negative so that's where we like is that
it's releases effect I just mentioned of
um gene expression regression via
promoter methylation
then it's followed here for instance by
score two or another thing finger
protein
CNF 121
and now we have times this teen
expression variable the cfp 57 and
effect it affects a lot of methylation
sites and sites and nicely and cfp 57 is
also known to contribute in methylation
memory of Parental origin and it
controls DNA methylation during the
earliest multicellular developmental
stages and multiple imprinting control
regions as written here and nicely also
in the context of cancer because we see
um basically this effect directly in
breast cancer specimens it's also nicely
that cfp was shown to suppress
proliferation of breast cancer cells
here inside publication shown it's a
button
and the next one in this list of hits
was again a thing finger party in
and it's also connected to 11 different
methylation sites again it's controlled
by its own promoter methylation and
nicely
CNF 334 was also identified as a tumor
suppressor and triple negative breast
cancer
recently as shown in this application in
the third
under the third point and now Dragon
suggests a mechanisms which is very
dominant Edge to its own methylation
side and that's in fact something a
pattern which is already observed in
other cancers like to Cellular
finally we ended up with this analysis
by a data integration since our
community detection approach and said
identified uh joined biomarker which
combines missylation with gene
expression and basically and we observed
that we can differentiate basal versus
non-bases subtypes of breast cancer with
an AUC walk of 0.5 mm eight five so it's
in fact I'm considering that it's just
one gene expression level and it's
corresponding for multiplication sets
indeed a pretty good number of course if
you incorporate many more
variables you might get substantially
better but it's remarkable that it's
just these two variables so basically a
multi-ohmics Synergy which we hear
um discovered
well the last few minutes
I'd like to show you how
this Concepts so basically the concept
of graphical model can be adapted to
spatially
um resolved omics data and first I'd
like to just State some basic things all
of us know so sales send chemical
chemical and mechanical signals
that's pretty clear
sales receive these signals and of
course if they receive these signals
there will be also some some Downstream
effects and that basically leads
um finally
um to set the cell that's molecular
phenotype
in other words so if I put for instance
here an additional sales or I added to
start say
isolation and that's basically simply
because
sales talk to each other
and in other words the molecular
phenotype of a cell depends on its
environment
and even more that means the combination
of sales molecular phenotype together
with the spatial context allows us to
better understand how cells communicate
with each other and how they organize
um in space and that's what we try to
estimate and basically our strategy was
to extend that language of um partial
correlation graphical models
um to the spatial context
and basically to to the spatial omics
context
and
let me first recapitulate what I showed
pretty much at the beginning of of my
presentation I introduced some some
language of conditional Independence and
Sarah mentioned that molecular variables
A and B are conditional independent
given C then a does not provide any
information for B which is not already
contained in C
and I just um repeated here because we
now use the same language
to
um and basically formulate what we call
spatially conditional Independence
and
so in other words I have molecular
variables now and on in different set so
for instance a molecular variable a in
cell a so where the capital A in cell
small a which is here shown as a capital
A with superscript a
and what it reads here is molecular
variables a in cell a and there will be
B in cell b are spatially conditional
independent given the rest
then a does not provide any information
for B which is not really
um already contained in rest of course
in cell A and B respectively and the
corresponding way of expressing this in
formula as shown here in the middle
importantly we need to specify for what
rest means so now really rest refers to
all variables of cell a
except capital A and all variables of
cell b except
um capital B
and of course all variables of all
remaining sets so basically that was our
strategy that what we now wanted to
encode into a model to infer cellular
communication so that's a it it's it's
not so straightforward to to get um used
to this
um terminology and I
really recommend you to look into a
blueprint which we just put on a
preprint server a few days ago
and which I show you in a moment
so however also we can State such a
yeah terminal also we can name something
like spatial conditional Independence
and that does not yet mean that we have
a model we can
um easily calculate and infects as
rather tough because
um spatial interactions are pretty
diverse and so for instance there can be
a short distance or something like say
contact
for us it can be long distance so we are
exchanging signaling molecules something
like
set
and that's now the blueprint which I
mentioned we called it space net for
spatial cellular networks from omics
data and the idea is to basically encode
these spatial conditional Independence
relation in an upscaled version of this
gaussian graphic and model so
computationally sets
um inflates a problem tremendously so
it's
D times n
a multivariate normal with P times n
variables but basically we
stack and individual sales profile
together and try and try to model this
within one single big multivariate
normal and then what remains is
basically said we need an
um yeah do it and reasonable way to
encode a code or C spatial associations
and what we did here something like
making a very general
um serious expansion which allows us to
model very different interactions like
sales contact and also something like
more long distance via some signaling
molecules
and basically to show you that this
works out and I just again in a
simulation study
show you here these red lines and
figures a to d these are
potential so basically how one molecular
variable in one cell affects
another molecular variable in another
cell
and that's basically through observances
and again and again so basically if I
have such an image slide or a spatial
transcriptomics data where I really have
an individual sales with their location
then they basically observe sales many
many times with different distances
different locations and that allows me
to estimate that with these
relationships
and
so for instance here from left to the
right something like
intermediate range is figure a long
range figure B and short range figure C
and figure T is something strange which
we also tried so something like there's
no molecular interactions if cells are
very nearby so there's a potential is
near zero and then molecular variables
affect each other across space for
reasonably large distances and then
again the interaction disappears for for
large distances
and in principle even something like
that can be reconstructed and the
different lines that I showed to you
here are different orders in our serious
expansion and in principles through
increasing orders we can model more and
more complex relationships
um I'd like to end up with some
illustration how how that basically
works and now we went a bit away from
from cancer and considered data from the
mouse visual cortex simply because
um appropriate data so that means a
position in space and
corresponding to that position in three
dimensional space or also in RNA
expression so it's still something which
is pretty Raw and you can see this data
set um there were 28 rnas measured in 30
000 cells together with their respective
location in a thick tissue section and
that's something
um that's where the space net is built
for and applying
space net
um yielded the spatial association with
associations between gene expression
variables here shown in this figure on
the right side and I just want to
mention our top hit
and and the the
highest spatial Association was observed
between Merlin basic protein Gene MBP
and FMS related receptor tyrosine kinase
1 FL T1
and indeed said fits nicely into the
literature so
um we were lean so that's basically
built
um to a high proportion by merely in
basic protein and this murlings around
nerve cell exons to insulate them and to
increase the conduction of electric
impulses and now flt1 on the other hand
encodes a member of the vascular
endothelial growth Vector receptor
vtfr family and these mediate diverse
cellular communication signals
controlling developmental processes and
now space net and resource that fat
levels are negative so I consider a
specific cell and then fat one levels a
negatively associated with MBP levels in
neighboring cells so that's basically a
kind of statement Spaceman Space net
provide services
and indeed it also fits nicely into the
literature so here in the part of the
diet Mouse
and it was shown that only to the
endocyte precursor cells contribute to
folk women
alienation and VHF signaling might be
required for the proliferation so it is
known that there are these OPC so one
one thing of course it space net just
generates let's say like that hypothesis
or indicates mechanisms and at least
it's
um nice to observe this very strong
negative association because it could be
some mechanism like there are for
instance axons which um lag MBP and then
basically all PCS which are the
remulinating cells group around these
axons basically to re-emulinate
them sets could be one mechanism of
course to further elucidate it's at
night require substantially and more
work and sets are very methodological
work so we are pretty much at the
beginning we now have a model which
incorporates all these aspects and now
we hope that we are looking forward to
more and more mixed data coming up to
try to generate really knowledge and I
also want to emphasize because that's
pretty much in this period of how
um my collaborators and I are working is
that we basically try to get a more
holistic view on our data so our data
have many
um a huge amount of information that
information needs to be integrated as
complete as possible and these Network
approaches are some kind of way of doing
this
and let me Briefly summarize so I
presented you first some Basics about
graphical models many groups in the
world have contributed
and we have here two blueprints out so
Dragon space networks are presented both
to you
so also I'd kindly like to thank all my
collaborators so it was really necessary
to combine forces to develop these
rather complex models and then of course
I'd like to acknowledge funding from
these two funding agencies bmpf and TFG
and Germany and I finally want to thank
you for your attention and I'm very very
happy to answer questions